a teen and her boyfriend who killed her
father learned their fate in court today
good afternoon thank you for joining us
at four I'm Kirsten Joyce and I'm
Christian Casa is it's a story the eight
news now investigators first broke
Vanessa Murphy with the very latest from
Court
the judge sentencing the teens to life
in prison with the possibility of parole
after 22 years served those were terms
specified in an agreement when the teens
pleaded guilty to murder and other
charges where did the evil come that was
bred into a soul that murders their own
father Christine hallseth delivering an
emotional statement about the murder of
her son Daniel you're in a tough spot
because your son is the victim and the
Killer is your granddaughter can you
talk about that
she's not my granddaughter Sierra Hall
Seth claiming her father abused her he
locks me in place and starts pushing and
hitting me around Aaron Guerrero
offering an apology
as I get sentenced today
the teens stabbed Hall Seth 70 times
tried to dismember and burn his body and
stole his car in an attempt to run away
in April of 2021 before their capture
welcome back to our YouTube channel they
recorded this video day three after
murdering somebody whoa the whole Seth
family insisting Sierra's claims of
abuse are false some saying they believe
the death penalty would be a more
appropriate sentence they [ __ ] have
gotten death with the life they took 20
years will never be enough for taking
down
halstead's loved ones pointing out how
Aaron Guerrero appeared to show remorse
and emotion while they believe Sierra
did not reporting from the Regional
Justice Center Vanessa Murphy 8 News Now
Sierra hulseth is also the daughter of
former Nevada Republican state Senator
Elizabeth hallseth she and Daniel had
divorced